[Musique]
angers caen aventure les appels
temporaire chers auditeurs nous
retrouvons iris elliott thomas et thomas
du futur en 15/100 3 à florence ils sont
à la recherche d'un malfaiteur qui
modifie le cours du temps mais qui est
il
j'ai lu vos théories dans les
commentaires c'est très intéressant
notamment celui de saitama zz qui dit
c'est ta mère qui modifie le temps cent
trente sept pouces en l'air assez beau
internet la renaissance l'âge d'or de la
peinture à l'huile
c'est romantique regardez j'ai nouvelle
robe magnifique ya bien comme sur le
titanic
on compte sur vous pour arrêter cette
personne qui modifie le temps et pour me
mettre cinq étoiles si vous êtes
satisfait du jeu
[Musique]
il a encore du sport là tout à leur
petit lapin suite après mais capteurs
l'anomalie viendrait de ce bâtiment
atelier de ligne vous avez lu c'est
l'atelier de léonard de vinci
la porte est fermée à bouger pas j'en
fais mon affaire
regardez léonard de vinci côté vous
essayer de contrecarrer les plans ou
eurobonds
n'essayez pas de me barrer la route je
fais ça pour le bien de l'humanité j'ai
un plan ou nac a renversé du coca dessus
comme j'ai fait avec mon ordinateur pour
ça je vais pas hétéro à quel courage
merci et lui c'est moi bien fait
j'accepte tout sur moi je veux faire
c'est vos bobos au collège regardez le
beau senna tu es fort mais pas assez
pour m'arrêter
qui es tu pourquoi détruire le temps
itri
nous améliorons de temps il ne faudrait
pas s'est échappé c'est un échec
je n'ai pas pu le neutraliser ne
t'inquiète pas tu t'es bien défendu ça
arrive d'échouer tout le temps au beau
j'ai récupéré une pièce détachée analyse
là tout de suite c'est te plaît elliott
car je suis un être vivant et sensible
pas de doute
eris ce robot vient bien de notre époque
mais qui s attendait messieurs voilà
vous êtes libre messieurs dicaprio de
vinci merci à vous étrangers cette
étrange femme voulait me voler mes plans
mais vous était arrivé autant c'est un
honneur de vous rencontrer
merci je suis très sensible à vos
oeuvres elle me procure des émotions oui
on est très émus de rencontrer un tel
génie mots je suis plutôt fier de mes
dessins d'armes
elles vont être dévastatrices oui vos
pattes sur son magnifique la scène la
joconde je conte comment vous êtes au
courant je n'ai même pas encore terminé
de la pub c'est parce qu'on vient du
futur quel thomas tu veut modifier le
temps court oui merde j'ai oublié du
voyageur du temps de monaco j'en ai
toujours en gérer en ainsi que d'autres
matériaux tétouan mes travaux sont
connus dans l'avenir et grave qui est le
film là davinci code nino mes armes
rotative par exemple plutôt les tableaux
but mais apparaît volant ça c'est plutôt
des prototypes moi c'est ça un dessin 21
de la une fourchette d'un côté une lame
de couteau blues
j'ai même fait un prototype j'ai appelé
ça le fourteau la couchette ça existe
deux jours mais si le manche de la
fourchette est une lame sa coupe la main
pour la preuve non ayo oui sa coupe la
maman salah le four thonon j'avoue qu'on
s'en souvient pas trop mais vous allez
marquer l'avenir avec l'âge au combat
bon c'est juste une commande le portrait
de la femme d'un marchand de tapis
je fais ça pour jouer
en plus elle est moche ils ont même
voulu que je le relève les scientifiques
et calmez vous vous serez c'est la grâce
à ce tableau a changée en orange tableau
jamais d'avis il prend visiblement mal
compliment vient jeter le tableau dans
la cheminée
hors de question que je sois connu et un
bravo iris vient de modifier le temps du
coup thomas a raison il faut remplacer
ce tableau pour rétablir le cours du
temps mais c'est demain si vous voulez
par peindre un tableau genre
j'aurais exactement le même que la
joconde non je vais faire un autre
projet qui sera réellement mouche chacun
veut peut-être que s'il refait haché
d'heure ça ne changera pas le cours du
temps j'ai plus on l'a modell quelqu'un
qui m'aide louis qu'il respire à
l'évidence je dois pas dragonnades bon
j'suis pas fan de poser pour un vieux
monsieur mais si c'est pour sauver le
temps les cheveux détachés ça pouvait
long pour toi tu essaies de belles
filles comme on en trouve plein partout
en revanche toi oui toi c'est toi que je
vais pas nui thomas du passé montrent
néanmoins que le garçon nos shows milieu
hostile à cette expression de subir le
bund
cette lâcheté débordante cette carrure
c'est révolutionnaire c'est différent de
la joie dans le corps
de la tristesse et le corps de la
tristesse
il me faut du mouvement s'est terminée
les pauses et statiques les mains
croisées
que fais tu quand tu es heureux tu
souris tu danses contre moi je veux une
russe une fois j'ai fait taupin
fortnight j'étais trop content alors
j'aide à b comme ça à manu fait les bras
en l'air
le nu dans les couilles vite mais pas
sauf à rester victoire on est tous je
dois pas drôle naturel c'est obligé non
c'est qu'il fait un peu froid mais je
dis ça comme ça mais qu'est ce qu'on a
fait j'espère que ça va marcher sinon
les bloqués ici pour toujours sur cette
route est celle où dois me concentrer
sur mon chandail
ok ok on va attendre dans le restaurant
en face honey west avec les prévient
nous en tenons s'il te plaît elliott tôt
avec plaisir thomas je reste avec thomas
dépassé monsieur de vinci un café je
cours
vous allez adorer et voilà comment merci
mais ça me fait plaisir qu'on prenne un
petit goûter seul
toi et moi c'est un plaisir pour moi
aussi la posture assise dans mon monde
c'est pas tous les jours
cet endroit est tellement romantique
dans mon monde je n'ai connu que la
violence et le sang de mes amis je dois
dire que ces trois-là quotas et
délicieux suis un peu embêté j'aimerais
te parler de quelque chose qui me
bouleverse
je sais ce que tu vas me dire et je
ressens la même chose non c'est vrai
j'ai l'impression que c'est mal et mais
c'est plus fort que moi il n'y a pas de
honte à avoir
c'est un sentiment naturel les six
spéciales quoi sensible où il montre ses
failles non il s'inquiète pour les sous
attends tu veux parler des temps
j'aimerais être à nouveau ce tome à la
boj pu le perdre autant chemin j'avais
oublié à quel point j'étais plus leurs
avants ce que j'ai vécu je suis je suis
choquée là je comprends que tu plus être
irrésistiblement attiré par cette
version de -1 6 étapes l'histoire quand
je regarde mes mains je vois la plus
lorsque j'étais au long du règne je
regarde mes bras et je vois les
problèmes que j'ai dû affronter je
regarde mes abdos et je vois des boues
de pierres taillées en profondeur
parcouru par des veines saillantes sur
ma peau fine et luisante
j'ai perdu mon innocence et ce jeune
thomas c'est tout ce que je recherche
il n'attend qu'une chose donner de noms
je voyais pas du tout ça comme ça les
amis le tableau est finie vous n'allez
pas être déçus ou peut-être que oui
[Musique]
voici mon set choix dans la politique je
valide ces mouvements le braz inédit je
les appelais le d'abord je suis à
chef-d'oeuvre dommage qu'on voit pas mon
visage le modèle étaient signées inspire
non j'ai caché les parties intimes avec
une toute petite pâquerette
ah bah c'est mieux comme ça alors pour
ma défense il faisait froid mais on est
loin d'être au niveau de la joconde là
c'est foutu
le tableur taylor s'il faut que vous
renvoyez into masse beaucoup plus
colorée cole ou qu'elle sheed on a
réussi à maintenir le temps oui
apparemment bien allez vous redéposer à
votre porte mais on va devoir faire un
nouveau détour et un nouveau problème
voyage à travers les époques
la chorale king grande aventure vous
appelle ccc bout qu'on va ratant
pénalisation bonjour madame
nous sommes arrivés n'oubliez pas le mot
mais 50 ont regardé mes bottes raymond
chopin nouvelle époque nouvelle rhodes
j'adore nous sommes en amérique hollande
y comprend jamais avec des dates elliott
tu peux être moins prisme hockey
simplification amérique du nord
18e si simple ok info courants forts
amérique et bob des cobras mais c'est
pour ça que vous êtes en cobol pourquoi
je suis encore habillées pareil d'après
mes capteurs l'anomalie est quelque part
dans la région
face à un canon à eau tu matière ben tu
vois saitama zz c'était pas ma mère qui
cherche à modifier le temps mais un
robot ne m'a jamais bien ma théorie sur
adolf hitler
mettez les chauds rayons étrange qui
traversent le ciel à l'époque des cadres
oeil j'ai aussi ma petite idée
merci d'avoir écouté ce troisième
épisode de l'épopée temporel et à la
semaine prochaine pour la suite